now you got handed a big present right
at the beginning of this question you
got headed a well what was the result
you remember what it was and plus 1 mm
is greater than 1 yeah okay good so you
have a look at this carefully look
carefully the first thing obviously is
well I have a particular value of AD in
mind so if I just write this all the
case that will get a little bit closer
to what I'm dealing with like so now
look closely at that and look closely at
what I've got over there how is it
different cuz look exactly what I wanted
yeah so you can see how I've got root k
minus k plus 1 I have it in the raw
water actually it's exactly what I want
in order to turn that into this I'm
gonna have to multiply both sides by
Midas wallet okay so the first thing
that will do is it will switch the
border of these two the second thing
we'll do is we'll obviously slap a minus
sign on there and then the third and
last thing it will do is it will change
the direction of the inequality okay is
that all right so now i can say or I'd
have a look at this this thing over here
our route k plus RL for these things
together route k plus one plus one okay
I'll just rearrange that okay this thing
according to partay I'm going to do this
same thing again and we're going to do
with red and green again ok this is
telling me that red is less than three
yeah so therefore if you like you can do
this a couple ways you just go directly
to the next line or if you want you can
put it over here this thing must be less
than i'm going to replace it now minus 1
over 2 k plus 1 okay do you see what I
did right again you've got this guy I
have the green in the wrong spot is less
than this guy yeah sorry that's not okay
so that's from party I should probably
write that because that's where it came
from Hey okay so this is this weird
thing that's happening with inequalities
right you can just bring inequalities in
there not equal to each other that's
what inequality means but they're bigger
and smaller than each other in an order
I could take advantage on okay right so
if I've got this thing smaller than this
thing just more than this thing then the
first piece should be smaller than the
last one okay does that make sense i'm
just going to say that that's there I'll
put this in a warm positive Horner okay
how are you feeling so far okay has the
logic held together at the moment and
importantly am I any closer towards this
goal this goal then I was the beginning
think I am right I mean the fact that
i've used number one the inductive
hypothesis and number two the sort of
the hint they gave me that suggests some
making progress so the question is how
can I get to the end how can I prove
this thing should be smaller than zero
any suggestions yeah might join you
so I'm suggesting this is bigger than
this as well I'll do it so hold on let
me think about this right I want to
prove i want to show this to be big
right so if I've got like a takeaway be
the second number of bees bigger then
the whole thing be negative that's good
that's what I want but at least in my
head that is not unlike how do you see
that right and I mean it is true this
whole thing is true but I'm not it's not
clicking for me what I want is something
to just a car obviously here's what I'm
going to do here's a bit of a unusual
step I know it doesn't look like it can
be factorized this pair of fractions but
it can write it can this here is root k
plus 1 times root k plus 1 do you agree
so I'm going to take out a factor of 10
on route k plus 1 and what does that
leave me with on the inside answer in
these me with this take away what okay
now this is better sao paulo better okay
because by breaking this apart have a
look at this tell me what you can what
you know about the sign of this thing it
must be positive okay so i don't need to
worry about him he doesn't change the
sign of the thing if this is positive
then this is the thing which must be
negative right now this is an easy
fracture so this needs to be smaller
than this what kinds of fractions are
smaller than half any anything with a
denominator bigger than to like if this
were three or a four or five but I know
what K is right so now that I've got an
idea of where I'm going to go in my head
here's the way i'm going to set up my
logic and this this part a lot of
hundreds are pleased with because it's a
bit longer than I'd like it to be but
the logic is sound and it's quite easy
to follow so watch I'm going to say fun
okay is greater than yourself yep now
what I want is I want to reach this line
or this expression right
and something that should tell me this
is smaller than this that's what I'm
getting to okay so how do I get there
I'm going to add one to both sides
because there's a k plus one over there
I'm going to take the square root of
both sides now just think for a second
does that does that make sense if I've
got a number that's bigger than others
oh no by the square root of their first
number will still be bigger do you agree
with that obviously is doing everything
deposit which it is okay what else can I
do here how we get over there what about
if I need a reciprocal dunno right so i
will take the reciprocal of this and the
reciprocal of this now if i told you for
instance 100 that's bigger than two and
then I compared their reciprocals what's
happened to the inner qualities are
score the other way right so therefore
this uniform is on the other way but
what is this number what every day
that's one on 2 root 2 which is like 2.8
do you agree so this is less than a half
right yeah and it's not it's not equal
to like this is definitely less than
okay so therefore I can say this guy is
definitely less than enough does that
make sense you see where I got here and
now i only need to do one more thing i
can say look one on i'm going to
subtract a half from both sides do you
see that do you see the connection right
so i would have that I mean my white
bones right on its face over here I had
that as part of our secondary logic and
now at this line i can say but that is
true one on route k plus 1 minus a half
is less than 0 and 1 i'm group k plus 1
is greater than zero so the product of a
positive number and negative number is
going to be a negative number right do
you see how i made that logical step
it's being kind of quite a few logically
to you but i hope you can see how
I did it that's positive that's negative
so the whole thing has to be negative
see less than zero and what if I got on
my left hand side in this guy what was
clear okay hey one last line to fit onto
his wife on her or loud right I'm almost
I'm almost there what was the result I
was trying to prove it was this line
wasn't it right so all i need to do is
keep this guy back where he belongs over
on the left-hand side i have the first k
plus 1 turns right and then i just add
root k plus 1 to both sides and that's
what I required so um what's hard about
this there are a number of times where
you have to look and the next step is
not like oh I just simplified okay and
that's kind of the thing about
inequality we have you ever say this
kind of budget like and about things
that are smaller than things on a
smaller number of things so therefore I
kind of connect all these I ideas
together and that's why it's extension
one right not only that but you've got
to pull it you've got to understand how
to know his work right like a fog on a
negative number and a positive number
what does that mean for my product of
those two